[Music]
i'm councillor reece pugh and i'm deputy
leader atlantic district council and
cabinet member for economic development
my name is brian horton i'm chair of the
margate town deal board i've been the
chair since november 2020. i've been
involved in the margate town deal not
only as a board member but as the
cabinet member for economic development
it's my responsibility to
put through to cabinet and to council
any of the the main projects and the
allocation of the funding and the money
and and stuff like that really
well i mean i think this investment will
benefit the town from the government
particularly in job creation um you know
i think also giving them much-needed
boost and a confident boost to not just
our local businesses but to the wider
community to show what success margate
can be the business cases have been
submitted to government they set out our
ambition for the town
the particular projects that we're
supporting and we're really excited
about the opportunities that they will
bring the ability both to improve the
health wellbeing and the financial
prosperity of the town
[Music]
well i think for me aspects of the the
town investment plan and the town deal
that i find exciting are the ones that
are going to give a boost to our tourism
market and our industry i think it's
incredibly important that we broaden our
horizons and broaden the offer that we
can can give to visitors and to tourists
into the local area i've not got a
particular favorite project i think that
you know we've got the skate park in
cliftonville which is a particular focus
on our young people
we've got the investment plan for both
the theatre royal and the winter gardens
which is an important part of the
culture offer for the town we've got
investment aimed at dreamland
and opening up the old historic cinema
there and a range of other things
bringing more people into the area for
different reasons not just to come to
the beach
and for them to come here and then
sample the other great things that we
have it's all part of our future as a
town both investing in the new things
the great things are happening but also
making sure that we don't leave the
local people behind and i think the the
range of things that we're doing is so
important for our future and a great
part of uh our ambition to make margate
a free six five seven day a week place
to live work and play
[Music]